nicolas dos reis sa vie son parcours
tout est passé au crible devant les
jurés aujourd'hui sa mère très affecté
par les événements est passé à la barre
sanglotante tremblante elle évoque un
sentiment de culpabilité
elle veut faire passer un message vous
est dû aussi à tous les gamins qui
savent et qui s'amuse à mettre le feu
aux poubelles que demain ça peuvent être
qu'ils sont aux assises que la prison
c'est pas de la tarte
les portables c'est à la télé on dort
dans les couloirs en prison ça à la télé
que c'est pas du tout comme ça que ça se
passe en prison et que vraiment qu'ils
pensent à leur famille avant de faire
des conneries comme ils ont fait les
miens
les experts sont d'accord sur plusieurs
points concernant le profil
psychologique de nicolas dos reis
c'est un garçon en manque éducatif naïf
et puéril
il a agi avec une grande immaturité la
rupture de ses parents semblent avoir
joué un grand rôle dans son instabilité
affective mais sur un point les experts
se contredisent
d'un côté nicolas n'aurait aucun traits
psychopathiques de l'autre il ans
présenterait les risques une divergence
mise en doute par ses avocats
on est face à un jeune qui a mis le feu
à une poubelle sur un moment
effectivement de d'absence de réflexion
et puis par bêtise tout simplement qui à
aucun moment ne s'est posé la question
des conséquences qui pouvait être
attaché à cet acte est cet acte a eu des
conséquences dramatiques dramatique
alors quand on nous parle effectivement
de pulsions destructrices
peut-être que ça peut être un trait de
personnalité mais en tout cas dans le
dossier qui nous retient je pense
absolument pas que ce soit le cas enfin
l'un des experts a ajouté que les deux
accusés selon lui étaient des compagnons
de galère mais qu' aucune fascination
n'existait entre les deux cousins
demain la course penchera sur le cas de
rémi kukulinski qui sur le plan
psychologique s'annoncent beaucoup plus
compliquées